all right you're gonna do an intro thank
you thank you I know it has taken over
direction I'm Greg with me is the lovely
and talented comedian actress youtuber
model Syd Wilder Syd Wilder you should
check out her channel hilarious sketches
on there does more than just sketches
she's got some fun challenge videos
we're actually I haven't talked about
some of the other videos we're supposed
to do a video together too for your
channel host to do one she's also a
model and she has some lovely photos on
Instagram where she's wearing like nun
outfits firefighting outfit fully
clothed can't even see her face it was
great it's fantastic
hmm grandma's right around the course we
can't making it too many appropriate
comments anyway we're gonna check out
the awesome channel one of my favorite
channels of all time top 5 unknowns they
do you like fun list videos they should
do animes maybe you'll be included one
of these days 5 internet celebrities who
were stalked by their fans have you ever
been stalked by a fan I've had some
really aggressive fans I'm here now how
are you tuber made it's all fake profile
everything I'm the guy sent you many a
pic on Instagram
oh gosh I'm very flexible very bendy
bendy gee is what they call me bendy
Jesus what
unknown yeah once you obtain some
internet fame you never know what can
come along with it unfortunately for
these internet celebrities
it was crazy stalker fan Tobey Maguire's
internet I think we will remember this
girl right if you don't then here's a
little background information box is a
character played by internet celebrity
Catie Wayne she started to become
popular in late 2008 and early 2009 in
January 2008 she recorded two videos in
them she was addressing her friends on
anime theme social networking site gaya
she uploaded the videos onto a YouTube
channel by the name of boxy babe
later on in the year the videos were
reposted to I am bored calm and from
here they spread to fortune and other
websites due to the rising popularity of
her videos she responded by posting a
third video in it she's wearing heavy
eyeliner and seems to be very excited
and Randall's about things with her
newfound fame came several cyber
stalkers mainly coming from imageboard
website fortune unfortune there was a
heated discussion between boxy
supporters and boxy haters they selected
several hacking incident members of
4chan were able to hack into boxes
account and receive her personal
information they lost her full name
address phone number and other personal
information that also revealed that she
was playing the character of boxy due to
the address leaked people had began to
start stalking her in real life haiti
began to receive phone calls from
obsessed people who asked her strange
questions bankers would shop at her
doorstep
some people had even went as far as to
sending her videos claiming that now
they know her address they're going to
murder her
they actually forced her to move home as
people kept appearing at her house
oh I post about it on Twitter claiming
that she had been forced to move to an
undisclosed location the attention had
died out during 2010 but she continued
to host videos on a new account in 2011
she uploaded a video explaining about
bots he was a character that she was
playing number four wow that's a lot of
information I was like okay first of all
why are people so obsessed I wasn't
really interested in the Internet at
that um years 2008 9 it and really care
I was like still reading like hardcopy
magazines like the backstage I had no
idea who she was that's crazy that
someone say looked down with all her
information and put it home morning I
well it works it's scary now I'm like
[ __ ] should you come to my house yeah I
don't know never know what information
I'll release no I have security cameras
like I know like in where is she oh
she's a big channel
what was her boxy character exactly yeah
what was the character it looked pretty
simple with the background look like
just the typical youtuber just you know
like talking to the camera I didn't
realize that was a thing all the way
back then she's like one of the oh geez
one of the oh geez wonder what she does
now we should google it not right now
more Hilton who is that let's find out
okay
and more Hilton as a model DJ an actress
she never claimed to internet fame in
2007 in 2008 she was very popular on
MySpace and also had a popular show on
state camp stickam was a live streaming
website in which users could submit
pictures audio and video but could also
a live stream with their fans not in
2008 a man by the name of Jeffrey
Weinberg became obsessed with a more and
started to cyber stalker previous to
this he had served a ten month sentence
for hacking into Paris Hilton cell phone
he enjoyed stalking celebrity
and hacking into their accounts one day
a more try to log into a myspace account
but she was denied entry how is that her
cellphone had also been disconnected it
turns out that Jeffrey had managed to
hack into her myspace account and also
hack into her cellphone he would read
through all of her messages on MySpace
and also listen to her phone calls at
the time this all occurred it's reported
at a.m. or was only 17 or 18 Oh or was
unsure to what was going on that was
unfilled Jeffrey that contacted her he
said that he will give her access back
to her myspace account as she had phone
sex with them and sent a nudes a more
quickly contacted the police and with
her help Jeffrey was arrested he was
charged to two years in prison for an
act of computer intrusion number three I
mean you think he deserves it yeah
disgusting don't mess with underage
children don't mess with um they they
make fun of you I could believe she was
that young like what I know I wonder if
her parents were like oh cool do
whatever you want
maybe she maybe she kind of asked for it
yeah I don't feel like anyone's ever
asked me for it I feel like there's
always an underlying thing when some
like when a young girl's like acting out
like that like I feel like you know
maybe there wasn't a dad around or like
no mom or like you know either of them
and that's why you're like you know kind
of trying to explore who you are trying
to figure out who you are too but like
my space I was on MySpace and I met a
lot of people through MySpace
- I actually met like rock stars and
stuff I couldn't imagine being stalked
at that age having everything hacked
into and that guy probably hopefully is
still behind bars and if he's not it I
feel really bad for the relationship
that he enters because he's probably
gonna know everything about that woman I
mean you gotta say that said the guy's
very talented he can like he can get all
that back all that
most of the government our is them hack
a cellphone am listening I didn't I
listen very impressive and I think you
could do that unless you live or like
we're so far away from someone's anyone
could listen to our phone calls at any
time it's hard not not where I live
getting serviced around here sucks
so beautifully it's really hard to just
pay attention to the camera and you when
all of this you have no idea what I'm
looking at right now it's beautiful it's
beautiful God's horizon is outside right
now all right oh yeah the video what's
new record quarterly rep versus a
glamour model and online personality she
posts revealing photos of herself on
Instagram in response she has lavished
thousands of followers on the site I
have seen her photos online a man by the
name of Luis placencia developed a
fixation of Courtney and started a cyber
stalker she said during 2012 she started
receiving strange emails from multiple
accounts one said I hope you don't
alternative and it crosses your ugly
face through the windshield
and a large piece of glass what's your
girl's photo he sent other disturbing
emails which said he was going to
decapitate her and cocktail parents up
into little pieces if she didn't stop
modeling what he became very worried
after reading the emails and informed
the police who contacted the FBI she
managed to trace her emails back to Luis
give it email from several different
accounts using computers at the Chicago
Public Library
police took medicine for questioning and
also searched his home they found that
had a collection of over 200 photos of
Courtney he'd also admitted that it went
to impersonated a photographer in an
attempt to get Courtney to pose nude for
him not only did he send emails he also
sent letters to her house and her
parents house Watney was so shaken by
the aura that she hired bodyguards to
protect her Lewis appeared in court to
face charges which carried a maximum of
five years in prison number two well
that's unfortunate I'm really sorry that
that happened
- Courtney I actually know her she was
the girlfriend of the guy who I used to
I the old home I used to live in he like
was like the house manager of it or
whatever and no girlfriends and she
always thought that I was hooking up
with him but I never was ever because in
a relationship at the time everyone
always thinks I'm hooking up with their
boyfriends or I want to hook up with
their boyfriends and I don't sorry but I
really don't I don't care who he is or
what he looks like I don't care she
would actually like accuse me of wanting
to be with that guy
she even sent me like she'd send me
messages like this big like I'm - I sent
her like accusing me yeah but she
apologized and sent me flowers so thank
you okay but I'm wondering now that I've
seen this like maybe what happened in
your past or her past like you know
cause that kind of anxiety to get
triggered if you've been stalked that
like you definitely have PTSD at some
point in your life this is the most
informally what I was not expecting such
information to be provided
no-nobody sorry that's great you know
and she was very fine tonight I
definitely accept your apology thank you
my stalker yet no but I didn't notice
she had one and I feel so bad I'm so
sorry that that happens it's never it's
never fair for anyone to have to suffer
through that because it creates a lot of
anxiety
I mean stalkers like that who like
download all their photos and probably
like you know attach themselves a lots
of something like that and they like
kind of blamed them for why they're so
drawn to them they take it out of them
and kill them that's crazy you can see
that I can see that they're trying to
project their feelings number-10 i'ma
tell graceffa joeygraceffa is a YouTube
celebrity the 24 year old from
Massachusetts two YouTube channels
joey graceffa and joey graceffa games
they have over 800 million views
combined in 2009 he began to post on his
main youtube channel he post baby blogs
but also post challenges and sometimes
music videos his popularity soon began
to spread and with it came millions of
fans and some stalkers in 2012 one
stalker went too far and hired
private investigator to find out what
it's believed that once a stalker got
this information they broke into Joy's
house this was hinted at by Joey in a
video he uploaded titled stalker he
hinted at a fan had broke into his
apartment his roommate even have to arm
herself with pepper spray and 2015
during an interview at VidCon he
admitted that a fan had hired a private
investigator to find out where he lived
there is little details about the case
so it's unsure on who the fan was or
what happened to them but in a stalker
video he had explained that he called
the police so they must have doubted the
stalker
so jealous of him I just you know I just
feel like no one's ever gonna stalk me
oh you'll have it I feel like that's
what I made it oh my gosh like they're
obsessed with me they want to harm me
but they love me no then I feel like I
would have made it that's really that's
a funny point of view to have and that's
a great joke but trust me in reality
thanks for like I have one right now and
I'm like trust me you don't want it cuz
I'm really good but no you don't you
don't want it that doesn't mean that
you've made it that just means that
other people have problems perhaps it
does I mean rather get a couple texts
some like nice girls than winning a
stalker that's hitting you up at all
times of the night and day well you know
I just don't know what it's like okay
you don't want to know I just want to
know you know I don't know it's like to
receive that kind of attention okay you
have more subs than me okay I wouldn't
you should never you know ever his subs
I don't even have four teeth oh I
definitely don't have 40,000 and you
have well half a million million yeah I
know none of them are stalking me
someone photos messages it's like it's
all in like light humor oh yeah don't
take her seriously well no one else guys
telling you if you want to stalk me hack
into my account or everything make for
an interesting story might even know
what a video I'll find out who you are
I'll try
my grandmother's FBI women when they're
determined they will find anything I'm
telling you not me is there any extra
question and beauty blogger youtuber and
author she started to a YouTube channel
titled so weather in 2009 initially it
started out as a blog but expanded into
the YouTube channel as of 2015 her main
channel has nine point two five million
subscribers and 600 million views second
channel more so Ella 13 million
subscribers in April 2015 she was forced
to be upload a video after she noticed
she accidentally revealed her home
address on camera after this several
fans and maybe even creepy stalkers
thought it'd be appropriate to show up
at her house and bring her door though
most friends only wanted pictures but it
was still quite inappropriate she made
several light-hearted post about on
Twitter a part of Solaris management
team stated that fans of youtubers feel
like they're allowed to be far more
intrusive because if you ever see
they're more like friends than
celebrities her boy yeah popular
youtuber Alfie deyes claimed that there
were people leaning over their guard in
the wall just to take a peek into that
house just to remind I'll of course
second channel called gruesome history
so go check out we make short work
directory style videos about strange and
disturbing events that occurred in
history or shorts go check it out thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
the video then be sure to get their big
thumbs up and don't forget subscribe to
keep updated with our videos goodbye
goodbye subscribe to top five unknowns
people that's so sad it's hard but at
least you know you've stood your ground
and stated your boundaries and Twitter
and you know kind of tried to fight back
in your own way and hopefully that
stopped I mean it's true what they said
about like a lot youtubers just talk to
the camera or do vlog so you feel like
you're just their friend I feel like
that's like this generation that's like
there are no celebrities like you get to
like you have a peek inside someone's
life and you get to know this
you know that connection so that's an
interesting scenario there where
scenario it's mono potato pinata said
does when she finds me funny funny funny
funny funny funny you got you got
talented kid you got so many chance but
you have no the fact that like a bunch
of people kept showing up they weren't
like they didn't seem like they were
just stalkers they seemed like oh this
would be cool she put out her address I
could just show up that see this video
and know not to do that to people
because that's not cool like think about
it this I heard a joke the other day it
was actually very well put I think it
was like Natasha Leggero and it was like
about a phone book or something like if
they're not responding back to your text
messages then you probably shouldn't be
showing up to their home so if you
didn't have their number don't show up
to their house email you mean actual
email not the business email well while
she has her opinion if you happen to
figure out where I live I will give you
you didn't want to say just let me know
we could do a reaction again did you see
my video about me wanting a stalker okay
I'd be so funny if a stalker showed up
you need a Craigslist ad for his
daughter oh man I'm all over Craigslist
alright guys well subscribe to top five
unknowns you can subscribe to the real
rejects especially if you want to stalk
me please okay look your I'll give you
mine you're talented and beautiful you
know what it's like to receive a ton of
attention I know it's late you know I
know anybody here know you know that I
know it's like no no no no he's my
prepared response or they go maybe
dangle the carrot dangled here no
Hollywood for you said
welcome to LA with New York accents now
please subscribe to sit Wilders channel
she has some awesome sketches on there
she does a lot of challenge videos she
does a lot of other types of videos too
you know it's not just you know one
thing but her sketches especially I've
I've only probably only seen your
sketches thank you yeah that's all I
care about
you don't care know who you are liking
videos and your person I'll [ __ ] that
man follow her on Instagram as well she
does a exclusive content now there yeah
and she does have photos that you can
admire that I don't look at cuz I'm a
good boy but he'll like them you just do
this i yeah yeah no I'm on her Instagram
all the time morning noon and night
thank you whenever I'm bored
using the bathroom whatever life of an
internet personality here right here